It’s tempting to think of marriage as old
fashioned. Why not just live with someone
and be done with it? What need for a public
ceremony? Why the weird traditions
all those churches,
temples, hymns, vows and prayers? Marriage
must be a silly relic from the religious childhood
of humankind, not designed for the more logical
modern world. And yet it survives. The essence
of marriage is to tie our hands, to frustrate
our wills, to put high and costly obstacles
in the way of splitting up. Why do we do this?
Originally, we told ourselves that God wanted
us to stay married. But even now, when God
is not invoked, we keeping making sure that
marriage is rather hard to undo. For one thing,
you carefully invite everyone you know to
watch you say you’ll stick together. You
willingly create a huge layer of embarrassment
were you ever to turn round and admit it might
have been a mistake. Furthermore, even though
you could keep things separate, marriage tends
to mean deep economic and legal entanglements.
You know it is going to take the work of a
phalanx of accountants and lawyers to prise
you apart. It can be done, but
it will be ruinous. It is as if we somewhere
recognise that there might, rather strangely,
be some quite good, though uncomfortable,
reasons why making it difficult to split up
a union can be an advantage for its members.
The Marshmallow
Test was a celebrated experiment in the history
of psychology designed to measure children’s
ability to delay gratification – and track
the consequences of being able to think long-term.
Some three-year-old children were offered
a marshmallow, but told they would get two
if they held off from eating the first one
for five minutes. It turned out a lot of children
just couldn’t make it through this period.
It was too tempting; the less immediate benefit
of gobbling the marshmallow in front of them
was stronger than the strategy of waiting.
Crucially, it was observed that these children
went on to have lives blighted by a lack of
impulse control, and fared much worse than
the children who were best at subordinating
immediate fun for long-term benefit. Relationships
are perhaps no different. Here too, many things feel
very urgent.
We’re angry and want to get out. We’re
excited by a new person and need to abandon
our present partner at once. And yet as we
look around for the exit, every way seems
blocked. It would cost a fortune, it would
be so embarrassing, it would take an age.
This isn’t a coincidence. Marriage is a
giant inhibitor of impulse set up by our conscience
to keep our libidinous, ungreatful, wild, desiring
selves in check. What we are essentially buying
into by submitting to its dictates is the
insight that we are (as individuals) likely
to make very poor choices under the sway of
strong short-term impulses. To marry is to
recognise that we require structure to insulate
us from our urges. It is to lock ourselves
up willingly, because we don't trust ourselves.
It's a very unusual marriage indeed in which the two people
don’t spend a notable amount of time fantasising
that they weren’t in fact married. But the
point of marriage is to make these feelings
not matter very much. It is an arrangement
that protects us from what we desire and yet
know (in our more reasonable moments) we don’t
truly need or want.
At their best, relationships involve
us in attempts to develop, mature and become
‘whole’. We often get drawn to people
precisely because they promise to edge us
in the right directions.
But It is too easy to seem kind and normal when we  keep going out with someone
new. The truth about us, on the basis of which
self-improvement begins, only becomes clear
over time. Chances of development increase
hugely when we don’t keep running away to
people who will falsely reassure us that there’s
nothing too wrong with us.
Over time, the argument for marriage has shifted
It’s no longer about
external forces having power over us:
What we are correctly now focused on is the psychological
point of making it hard to throw it all in.
For the last fifty years, the burden of intelligent effort has
been
on attempting to make separation easier.
The challenge now lies in another direction:
in trying to remind ourselves why immediate
flight doesn’t always make sense; in trying
to see the point of holding out for the second
marshmallow.